welcome to the show everybody thanks for
being here thank you for for listening
Justin Fairfax
lieutenant governor of Virginia as
you've heard has been accused of sexual
assault the accusation comes in the
midst of all the Ralph Northam stuff and
the governor in the midst of his you
know people calling for him to resign
because of his sordid history of
blackface and moonwalking when really he
should just resign because because he
supports killing killing babies after
they've been born now personally I don't
think it's a coincidence that all of
this I don't think it's a coincidence
first of all that the Northam stuff came
out with a black state blackface stuff
in the yearbook all of that that came
out only days after Northam had
committed the cardinal sin of
embarrassing the pro-abortion position
embarrassing it by by actually being
honest about it and taking it to its
logical conclusion so he committed that
sin that's not going to go unpunished if
you're a Democrat I don't think it's a
coincidence and then of course it's
obviously not a coincidence that that as
Fairfax is on the on the eve of
potentially being elevated to this
position that this comes out about him
so it would seem like Democrats maybe
leaked the the stuff about north um in
order to get Fairfax in there then north
oblique the stuff about Fairfax in order
to keep himself in there and then so
it's just I don't know you know I don't
know but it's just it's a mess all
around so what are the allegations
against Justin Fairfax basically the
accuser says that she was forced to
perform sex acts on Fairfax at a hotel
during the 2004 Democratic convention
she apparently went into his room
they started kissing and then she was
forced to perform the act that's what
she claims right allegedly it's it's
worth noting that the Washington Post
was told about these allegations a year
ago and decided not to run with the
story because it's uncorroborated hmm
now as for Fairfax he forcefully denies
it he he even
I would say angrily denies it I mean
he's angry in his denials of this of
this of this charge which really raises
questions about temperament I mean you
have to ask is he fit to be governor
with with a temperament like that a guy
who would get angry yet at rape
allegations if he didn't do them that's
just well we can't have that right
that's that's that's that's scary that's
weird
and of course that's the inevitable
comparison here to Brett Kavanaugh I
mean I'm being now obviously I think it
makes sense if you are innocent of a
rape accusation it makes a lot of sense
to be angry about it
so I think actually anger and emotion
that makes me even more convinced of
your innocence because that's how a
regular guy who who was innocent would
actually respond but that's not what the
left said about Brett Kavanaugh is it
and remember the post had no problem
running uncorroborated claims about
Brett Kavanaugh no media outlet had a
problem with that yet with Fairfax they
suddenly have this great caution they
suddenly are oh well we can't we can't
do that it son korabl with you know we
we the what the Post said is that they
looked into it they try to find other
witnesses and people that could back up
the story and they couldn't find that so
they didn't run it well they couldn't
find it with Breck have and I'll either
in fact it's worse than that not only
could they not find corroborating
witnesses for Brett Kavanaugh his
accuser but they actually found
witnesses who were more on Brett
Kavanaugh side who actively denied ever
being ever seeing this happen or being
in the same room as these people so they
actually found witnesses that Continent
actively contradicted Christine Ford's
claims yet they ran with that anyway and
but not only did the was the media
uninterested in these allegations
against Fairfax a year ago they still
are uninterested the media has already
tried to move on I went to CNN's home
page this morning and I don't know as of
this morning on CNN's home page there
was not a single word about
in Fairfax on the entire homepage and
we're talking about dozens and dozens
and dozens of stories get crammed onto a
homepage on CNN's homepage and they
couldn't find room for this story at all
which is insane of course because this
is a big story this is a big meaty
twisted kind of weird political story
this is the definition of news and it's
happening in Virginia in the media's own
backyard
yet they've already tried to move on
from it how long did it take them to
move on from Cavanaugh they were talking
about that for weeks but for Fairfax a
day later they're already done with it
how do these alligator were in the
middle of this comparison how do these
allegations stack up against Cavanaugh
well let's think about it for a minute
Christine Ford didn't know the year or
the location of her alleged salt assault
and she waited 30 years to tell anybody
this accuser waited only 13 years and
she knows the exact date time and
location and on top of that Fairfax I
believe admits that he knew the woman
that even they had a sexual encounter
only he says that it was consensual
whereas in Fords case Cavanaugh denies
even really knowing her being around her
and they couldn't find anyone that could
even corroborate that they'd been in the
same room together so you see that's the
problem here that it's it's very clear
that the allegations against Fairfax are
certainly more credible than the
allegations against justice Cavanaugh on
every level there is no when you do a
point-by-point comparison there is not
even one single point where it would
seem like Ford's story is more credible
than the story that Fairfax accuser is
giving us now
all things being equal I I would have no
problem with the Washington Post passing
on Justin Fairfax's story passing on the
story of his accuser I would have no
problem with them passing on that in
fact again all things being equal that
would be the right thing to do that
would be the responsible thing to do
because even though these allegations
are certainly more credible than the
allegations against Cavanaugh they still
are uncorroborated she has no witnesses
she has no evidence to provide
apparently at least none that she's
she's come forward with yet so it's only
it's only one accused I mean how could
you you run with this so it's the
responsible and right thing to do to say
no we're not we're not going to do
anything with that the problem though is
that of course they don't pass on
similar stories about Republicans so
their decision not to run with the
Fairfax thing that wasn't them being
responsible or them being cautious or
that them try you know it wasn't that at
all there wasn't journalist journalistic
standards no it was just this is the
wrong political party the media wields
sexual assault allegations as weapons
against their ideological opponents
which is so despicable that it is almost
beyond description
you know I'll sometimes I will sometimes
talk to people people who are more on
the left end of the of the spectrum and
people who don't really who still don't
really understand why conservatives hate
the media so much and they think of it
as kind of a silly thing that we're
always complaining about the media and
they think that we're kind of
fabricating this this conspirator we're
just we're all bunch of paranoid
lunatics who have this conspiracy theory
that the media is out to get us they
really just don't get it
well if that's if that's the case for
you and you're watching this and you
want to understand why conservatives
hate the media so much well this is the
freezin right here okay just compare the
way justice Cavanaugh's accuser was
treated and the way those allegations
were treated
and the way that they were amplified and
then compare that to more credible
allegations against Fairfax but the way
that those are treated and rather than
amplified buried just look at that and
then tell me I mean can you honestly
tell me that there is not political bias
at play here what other explanation
could you come up with other than that
all right one other thing I wanted to
mention in this realm related to the
Virginia mess yesterday I said that I
don't think Northam design because he
wore black lace 30 years ago I don't
think he should resign for that reason I
think he should resign because he
advocated and fantasized last week
that's the reason I think he should
resign
I heard her and I wrote about this as
well and I heard from several people who
said that who kind of took issue with
that and they accused me of downplaying
the blackface thing or even justifying
it I was accused of justifying blackface
which of course is not what I said
my point simply is that once again all
things being equal I would not support
the political destruction of a guy over
insensitive behavior from his college
days decades ago now it is very bad to
wear blackface of course and he was old
enough to know better and the incident
was recent enough it's not like this
happened 70 years ago I mean this was in
what the 80s so that was recent enough
that the whole well it was a different
time excuse doesn't hold up as well I
mean it was a different time but it was
still the 80s and everybody knew in the
80s that you weren't supposed to wear
blackface so that's all true but I still
think that a man can do stupid offensive
inappropriate things even racist things
when he's young and then he can grow and
change and he can become a decent
respectable adult we have to allow as a
country we have to allow P
people to grow we have to allow them to
change especially over now it's one
thing if someone does something horrible
yesterday and then the next day there's
they're claiming that they've undergone
some sort of some sort of epiphany or or
whatever people don't change that
quickly so that's true you know you have
to understand human nature but people do
change over the course of 30 years and
it's very common for a guy in his 50s to
be completely different to be a Comus a
different person entirely from the
person that he was in his early 20s or
even for someone in their early 30s to
be totally different from how they were
in the early 20s is it's a very common
thing people people grow and sometimes
you can sometimes it can it can be
pretty sudden and happen pretty not not
overnight but you know often times that
you just look at the difference between
someone who say 28 versus someone who's
23 it's only a five year difference but
it could really be night and day and so
we have to allow that we can't always be
forcing a person's younger self on their
older self and trying to put them in
this box keep them contained in the box
that they built when they were young and
never allow them to break out of it
the difference though with Northam is
that we know that he never grew into a
decent and respectable adult now perhaps
he stopped moonwalking with shoe polish
on his face although who knows but he
has since graduated to much worse
offenses and now he's out there
advocating for killing babies so in his
case we know that he that he didn't grow
that much at least not morally if he's
advocating infanticide but I do think
it's an important point generally for
the next time something like this
happens because the truth is even though
he's a Democrat if it weren't for the
infanticide thing even if you even
though he was a Democrat if this thing
had come out about the black phase I
would be saying no I don't think you
should resign over that now if you can
prove to me that he was wearing
blackface yesterday then we have a
different story
but if if it if it become if it's
apparent that it happened back thirty
years ago hasn't happened since then
then he's just changed you know he
changed it let him apologize let him
repudiate his past and then move on but
again it's different in this case
because of because of the infanticide
issue but I do feel the need to
stipulate that when I call for him to
resign and I do call for him to resign
not that it matters what I say but it's
because of the infanticide thing and
that that's what I think we should all
be focused on speaking of infanticide
let me see if I could pull this up
really quick here Daily wire has the
story on Monday senator patty Murray
blocking a Senate bill that would
require doctors to give aid to babies
who survived abortions objected to the
born alive abortion survivors Protection
Act and her one vote was enough to
prevent the Senate from passing the bill
in a unanimous consent vote so we don't
need to dwell on that because this is we
know this is where the Democrat Party is
but this is just to highlight the fact
that this is where this this is what the
Democrat Party has become that you can
even this was a bill that was it wasn't
an anti-abortion bill this was just if a
baby is born alive you have to give it
basic medical care that's all it's
really got nothing to do with abortion
but even that couldn't get passed the
Democrat Party which is just terribly
despicable all right I want to get to
the to the inbox now and check a couple
of emails actually I'm gonna answer two
emails
both theological or one theological and
one more historical I guess but they're
really interesting questions and I want
to leave myself time to really get into
them so we'll do that now if you want to
send an email to the inbox Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com
all right this is from Maddie she says
Matt I really appreciate your show
thanks for what you do I had a sort of
random question that maybe you won't
feel like answering on your show I was
recently talking to a Calvinist friend
of mine who claimed that some babies who
died end up going to hell she said that
the Bible backs her up as someone who
has had miscarriages this was very
upsetting to hear I then went and
researched it and found that she's
definitely not the only Christian who
thinks this apparently even some of the
great theologians in history have taught
this I find the idea of very hard to
stomach what is your take well first of
all I have also encountered this idea
and Maddie hope you don't mind I
mentioned your email on Twitter last
night not not by name but just that
someone had brought this subject up and
what I found is that now you know just
this is just kind of anecdotal but most
of the people responded on Twitter we're
definitely against this idea but there
were there were certainly a few more
than maybe more than a few who also feel
the same way not only believe that
babies could be sent to hell but are
seem to be somewhat attached to the idea
they insist on it
insist that we must at least be open to
the idea that this could happen which is
very strange to me that somebody would
not only believe it but it but insist
upon it passionately now also this is
not exclusive to Calvinists and I think
that most Calvinists probably rejected I
think most members of any denomination
or branch or type of Christianity reject
this idea but there are people as I said
Christians of all stripes who do feel
this way or who think that babies might
not go to hell per se but are denied
entrance into heaven and so essentially
they enter into some sort of cosmic
solitary confinement for all eternity
which is the same thing as hell that's
as much a hell as hell so you know this
effort to find an in-between spot for
all eternity where the babies will just
linger there forever separated from
from God well that's that's the same
thing as as them going to help here's
what I'll say I absolutely reject this
notion and I think that you should too
and I think everyone should and I think
you're perfectly safe and rejecting it
and not taking it seriously I find it to
be repulsive insane incoherent I don't
care what theologian taught it I don't
care that Saint Agustin held this view
st. Agustin was very brilliant a lot
smarter than me but I think he was
horribly wrong about this and so the
fact that what you you know just
starting when people start name-dropping
theologians
okay well that's they can be wrong right
they're they're they're fallible that
they're not right about everything and
this was an idea that was you know
gained popularity I guess we could say
if we'd call it that in the Middle Ages
and has since fallen out of favor so I
would look at it more as just a kind of
trend of thought in the Middle Ages and
that's all we don't have to land it any
more credence than that now it's true
that the reason why there are some
Christians who say well I don't think
get that God would do that but I I have
to be I'm open to the idea that maybe he
does and the reason why person say that
is because the Bible doesn't explicitly
address this question and that's true
the Bible does not it doesn't doesn't
explicitly answer now there are a few
verses you could cite and go to to talk
about God's approach to to babies and
and and all of that kind of thing and
that's fine but I also but I feel like
I'm not gonna start throwing verses at
you because verses can be thrown back
and forth and when you have an issue
like this where the Bible doesn't
explicitly answer it then you end up
with this quote mining this this kind of
cherry-picking proof texting thing or
people are just throwing verses out of
just ripping verses out of context here
and there and throwing them back and
forth like a food fight and I think it's
totally fruitless and it leads to
nothing in the end so I think with a
question like this rather than
texting and ripping out quotes and just
throwing them and saying there you see I
think we can use our faculties of reason
actually to figure it out because God
does give us our faculties of reason
this is this is something that God has
given us so we can use it now that
doesn't mean that our faculties of
reason are infallible or that we can
always trust what we happen to think but
we can use our reason and in fact even
when you go to the Bible you're using
your faculties of reason to understand
what it is telling you so if you're
gonna so someone who says well we can't
trust our reason at all well then what
do you even do why are you why are you
have why are we having any conversation
about God why would you ever read the
Bible
because you're using your reason to so
there's a look dogs and cats can't read
the Bible because they have no faculties
of reason at least not in the way that
we do so you must be able to trust that
or there's no point to anything so using
our reason I think we come to a
definitive answer and it goes like this
God is all merciful all just all loving
if he is not those things then our faith
is wrong and our faith is hopeless and
everything is hopeless right so if we
have our faith then we must believe that
God possesses those attributes and
possesses them perfectly we must also
believe that we as humans have some
understanding of what those words mean
now people will say well we humans can
never know what God's mercy is like we
could never understand God's mercy well
we can never fully understand it that's
true but when we say we can't understand
it that's a matter of degrees we're not
saying that we literally have no idea
what the word mercy or love even means
at all we're not saying that or we
shouldn't be saying that because if we
don't know what those words mean at all
it's true we don't have a full
understanding we may even have just a
small smidgen of understanding but if
you're saying that we have no
understanding of those words then it's
incoherent to attribute them to God if
we have no clue what the word mercy even
means then to say that God is merciful
like saying God is flippety-flip it just
it's a word that has no meaning why are
you even saying it it's nonsense
doesn't mean anything also if we don't
know don't know what those words mean
then we have no business saying that we
love our kids we have no business
calling others to be merciful we have no
business punishing anyone in the name of
justice also if we have no idea what
those words mean then Jesus was
incoherent in what he said that it was
incoherent for Jesus to exhort us to be
loving and to be merciful and to be just
which he did the fact that he's telling
us to be those things must mean that we
can understand what that what those
words mean otherwise it would otherwise
again he might as well just said yada ya
bloody blah blah blahdy blah that that's
that's basically what if you say we have
no idea what those words mean that you
have reduced Jesus's words to that just
complete nonsense because we can't even
begin to grasp them but the main point
again is that we if we don't know what
love and mercy and justice are if we
don't know at all on any level then we
cannot have any confidence that God
actually is loving and merciful because
those words are meaningless to us so we
must trust we have to trust that our
fundamental basic understanding of those
words contains some framework of basic
truth and according to that framework a
framework that again we must be able to
trust on some level or else everything
is nonsense a framework that God Himself
gave us an understanding that he endowed
in us according to that it is the very
definition of unjust unmerciful unloving
to punish infant children with an
eternity of conscious torment or or or
even an eternity of cosmic separation to
punish infant children eternally
according to any definition we can
conceive is totally unjust unmerciful
unloving it is in fact abject ly evil if
it is not evil then how can
call anything evil we have no business
calling anything evil if that is not
evil because then our idea of Evil's
also who knows and if we must have a
definition of mercy if the definition of
mercy
has to include trillions of years of
separation or torture for babies then
the word mercy ceases to have any
meaning at all so that's all because of
that whole progression of what I think
is logic we can conclude that if we
believe that God is loving merciful just
then babies go to heaven I mean that's
because there is no anything else would
be the opposite of mercy and justice and
I don't just because the Bible doesn't
explicitly say something I don't think
we need to entertain the notion that God
would do something horribly evil like
punishing babies for eternity by the way
there's another problem here you know
because imagine that babies are sent off
to hell or to you know wherever all
floating in space somewhere separated
for all eternity and then you get to
heaven and you know you're looking
around for your children that have died
and they're nowhere to be found right
now I know I'm speaking in human terms
here but you get what I'm saying and
then at that point I assume you would
have some knowledge of the fact that Oh
babies are actually being tormented for
all eternity well heaven is suppose to
be a place of perfect joy and perfect
love and perfect perfect happiness how
could you possibly as a thinking and
compassionate person find joy knowing
that every moment of joy that you
experience there are babies suffering
eternal torment in order to still have
joy you would have to basically be a
sociopath you would have to say that
yeah I don't care about that I got mine
I'm good
so again there's another logical problem
here that the sort of people who would
get to heaven would be exactly the sort
of people who could not possibly have
joy knowing that that is happening to
babies and then what do you do are you
cast out of heaven too because you can't
figure out how to have joy because
you're too worried about babies and so
you're punished then for your compassion
it just doesn't make any sense it's
totally illogical totally irrational and
I would absolutely reject it all right
from Ashley she says hi Matt loved the
show I was hoping you could you could
help me with something I was talking to
someone yesterday who claims that Jesus
never existed at all I've heard people
claim before obviously that Jesus was
just a prophet or a revolutionary or
whatever but not the Son of God this is
the first time I found myself arguing
with someone who denied he existed at
all
he had a lot of facts that seemed
impressive and I didn't have a good
response because I hadn't studied all
the arguments he presented I'm wondering
how you would deal with this argument
Thanks hi Ashley yeah this is this is
called the myth assist position or
mythos ism it definitely is a minority
position even among liberal New
Testament scholars and historians almost
everyone who studied this issue has come
to the conclusion and a minimum that
Jesus existed even guys like Bart Ehrman
and who's an atheist and one of the most
prominent New Testament scholars he
believes at least that Jesus existed so
that's the very first thing I would
point out to your to your mythos this
friend in it's not an argument from
Authority it's not like you're saying
well all these people over here believe
it so you must it's just a way of
putting their position into perspective
they might not realize how out there
their position is and and I do think
that when you don't have a lot of
knowledge and are not very informed and
then you go and you look and you see
that people who are very informed on
this topic disagree with you we can call
it an argument from Authority fine but
that should as a if you're a smart
person that should give you a reason at
least to think twice when you look and
you say oh everyone who knows more about
this than me disagrees you know maybe
I'm wrong but aside from that as far as
the arguments I you know I've read the
mythos its arguments I've read guys like
Robert price Richard carrier
probably the two most well-known missus
torian's I don't know any others I know
those two and here's what I'll say about
them about this idea that Jesus never
existed
I actually agree to an extent with the
way that they frame their argument
obviously I don't agree with the
conclusion of course but I agree with
this part okay because this is what they
say if you are this is basically their
argument that if you're going to reject
the supernatural elements of Jesus's
life if you're going to throw out the
miracles and the resurrection and the
intent and everything if you're gonna
throw all that out then you really have
to throw out Jesus too
you can't really separate him from the
supernatural that's what the myth
assists would say it just doesn't make
any sense to do that and this effort to
kind of sculpt a regular non
supernatural non-miraculous Jesus from
the big stone block of the Gospels is
absurd that's what myths just would say
and I agree with them on that I was
listening to a debate recently with with
Robert price and I forget who he was
debate he might have been William Lane
Craig I can't remember but he basically
said he basically said look once once
you get rid of the miraculous stuff
there really isn't much left there's
there's not much left to work with there
after that and that's true because think
about it let's go through Christ's life
for a second so you start with his with
the infancy narratives obviously well if
you're a naturalist rejecting the
supernatural
then you got a that whole thing is
miracle top to bottom the whole whole
infancy story so you got to throw all
that out you know virgins virgin birth
angels appearing stars travelling across
the sky so on and so forth so you got to
get rid of that if you reject the
supernatural and then we have nothing at
all for Jesus for the first 30 years we
have that one incident when he's 12
years old in the temple but again from a
naturalist perspective you got to get
rid of that because without divine
without any kind of divine involvement
it doesn't make any sense he'd have a 12
year old boy teaching rabbis in the
temple for three days so you throw that
out there so we've got nothing until we
get to Jesus as public ministry then you
have the baptism well maybe you keep the
baptism
then you have God from from the heavens
saying this is my beloved son obviously
you get rid of that so then the baptism
just becomes sort of a non-event it's
just one baptism among many others then
Jesus goes into the wilderness he's
tempted by the devil so you throw that
out if you're if you're if you're a
naturalist and then in John's Gospel
around this time we have him cleansing
the temple which I think you have to
throw that out too because without
divine intervention it doesn't make any
sense that Jesus wouldn't have been
arrested right there on the spot and
killed right then and there for doing it
so so that's gone and then we have the
Sermon on the Mount and and this is
where the kind of liberal historians who
still believe in a historical Jesus this
is where they kind of latch onto this
sort of stuff and they say well okay now
see now it's here's where we have a real
Jesus where he's giving his teachings
and Jesus was just a teacher he wasn't
the Son of God well there's a problem
there too because the full Sermon on the
Mount given in Matthew is several pages
long Matthew's Gospel wasn't written
until 30 or 40 years later so unless we
believe that Matthew had a big papyrus
scroll there on the hillside and you
know and he had his his pen and he had
brought up a table and was was
transcribing everything as it was
happening right there and on the
hillsides which probably didn't happen
then it wouldn't make any sense from a
naturalist perspective that 30 or 40
years later he could remember verbatim
this three or four page speech that
Jesus gave it makes sense from a
supernatural is if you're a believer if
you're a Christian then you believe the
Holy Spirit guided him but again I'm
saying from a naturalist perspective
that doesn't make any sense so I think
you have to throw that out too and then
you know then we have a whole bunch of
miracles we have exorcisms so all that
goes out in the end what are you left
with you're left with a guy who got
baptism God got baptized got into some
arguments with with the Jewish
mucky-mucks high priests of the time and
then was killed the end that's your
whole story but why would such a person
inspire all of these extra legends why
why would you need such an irrelevant
simple boring life as the template for
the extravagant mythology that followed
him it doesn't make any sense
think about it in
ancient world you know you had guys
because this is the liberal kind of
theory is that Jesus was a normal guy
and then legends attached to him like
barnacles on a ship or something
well that would happen with guys like
Alexander the Great someone like
Cleopatra or Julius Caesar people that
were already significant and great and
known throughout the land those are the
kinds of people that you have this
legendary embellishment that gets
attached to them it didn't happen with
just normal guys
it didn't happen with like just the Joe
the Plumber of the ancient world which
is what Jesus would be if he was not the
Son of God so it doesn't make any sense
not to mention if you reject the
supernatural then why would you trust
anything in the Gospels in the first
place because there's supernatural stuff
on every page in every paragraph so my
point is what we really have rather than
CS Lewis's famous trilemma where he
talked about Jesus was either a lot liar
Lord or lunatic we actually have a die
lemma I think it's more of a dilemma
Jesus was either Lord or he didn't exist
I think those actually are the only two
options Lord or legend the middle ground
does is non-existent for reasons I've
explained so you have to choose between
the two but if you choose the latter if
you choose legend you've got serious
problems first of all how is it that a
person could have been invented out of
whole cloth that quickly and then his
existence believed by everyone and and
this character worshiped all just out of
the blue and practically overnight
that's not how mythological characters
are usually that's not how it works with
characters who are really invented and
then later believed it doesn't happen
that quickly like someone just makes
them up out of the blue and then
everyone's and then everyone says
immediately oh yeah sure okay second why
is it that we have no record of any
critic of Christianity in the ancient
world and there were a lot of critics
ever accusing the Christians of
inventing Jesus out of whole cloth
nobody ever accused them of that they
accused Christians of lying or you know
hiding the body or whatever but nobody
nobody in the ancient world argued that
Jesus didn't exist
that wasn't a theory that anyone held
even people who hated Christians and
there were a lot of them nobody ever
said well this guy never existed will
you talk about you made him up nobody
said that third how do you account for
Paul no rational person denies that Paul
existed no serious scholar denies that
Paul authored at least six or seven of
his epistles although really he authored
all of them that are attributed to him
everyone agrees that Paul was operating
as a Christian within a few years of
Christ's death everyone agrees that Paul
knew and worked with Peter so how did
Paul come to believe in the existence of
this imaginary character forth who made
the story up and when and why remember
the Gospels were written decades after
Paul's epistles so there was a community
of people who believed in Jesus before
the Gospels were written so we can't say
that the Gospel writers made an up made
him up the Gospels came after the story
was already out there which means that
the Gospel writers couldn't made it up
which means that some person would have
just had to make it up and then pass it
along as oral tradition and then it
turns into Gospels again this is not how
it usually works with mythology fifth
you have just Cephas and Tacitus who
were Roman historians of the time and
they never you know they they both
mention Jesus they both affirmed his
historicity they never made any mention
that he didn't exist or that anyone
thought he didn't exist so in order to
reject that Jesus existed you must
reject everything in the Gospels
everything in the epistles the
documentation of Josephus the
documentation of Taz it is the testimony
of non canonical epistles like like
Clement all of that you have to throw
out completely which brings us to
another problem is that once you've done
that once you've some airily dismissed
all of this evidence and all of this
documentation how can you justify
believe in the existence of any ancient
figure at all because at that point you
know that is more attestation for at a
minimum Jesus's existence than we have
for the existence of many ancient
characters or ancient figures I should
say so if you're gonna do that with
Jesus then you have to you have to hold
every person in history to that standard
which means you've ripped history apart
and it's like history just started at
200 years
at that point it just doesn't make any
sense so in summary it is impossible to
separate Christ from his miracles it is
also impossible to separate Christ from
history which seems to leave us with
only one option whether we like it or
not which is that Jesus not only existed
but wasn't is the son of God that Ashley
is what I would say the next time that
comes up and I will leave it there
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed